[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where you going ernie tell the folks
what you're doing out there
a little rustic antique brick on the
wall
make it look a little bit like the old
stash from mammoth street
[Music]
what's up back again with another
episode of project stash just want to
give you guys a quick update where we're
at
so we got a lot of this stuff in the
stash it's almost ready to go most of
the uh
inspections or rough inspections are in
dumb or waiting for the finals
but what you can see is we got the
counters pretty much all ready to go
this is a product called flex land they
get from a company called outward
plastics they make all different types
of laminations
this is a pvc product made out of
plastic
it's got a great look to it
it's right at home it's kevin smith
approved that's all i care about
new comics old comics mike zapsic
johnny will young cousin johnny
getting all the comics back and back in
order how's it going there mike
who knew there were so many goddamn
comic books
holy crap there's a lot of comics here
everybody got to come by
yeah please do yeah come by and see
johnny can get it raised i'd like to get
a land rover
i got my nephew still here he just
helped me clean up
we got the sign up finally the big dog
you see that we got it all lit up it's
beautiful beautiful
[Music]
wow
that's nice but you know what chris used
to go
they'd have for us on something like
this so now
before that it was whale oil lamps
man get them getting to tell them steve
they have room all squared away
all the tech stuff i know nothing about
pluto tv that's how it is you're trying
trying to get pluto tv we got 148 on the
job yeah everybody
in the back my man wayne's still here
fixing the cabinets
and then get him his layer back here the
whole ebay section
it's much nicer than last time it's a
little nicer we're still a little bit of
a mess but we'll get all the stuff
cleaned out here the place to look great
and then downstairs i'll give you a
quick look at what you got down here
so as you seen before when i brought you
down here the layers the dwellings
the undercarriage of the stash this is
the new storage area where all the gear
is all that's all the stock for the
secret stash
all tidied up the guys did a great job
down here so it goes all the way back we
got it
full of merchandise well organized still
a little bit of a
cleanup to do but as you can see we got
a lot of stuff to tell you guys
way back way back and then that's the
private stash in the back
we won't go into there but that's a lot
of the goodies back there
but it's getting there everybody so
check us out next time
on project stash
[Music]
you